protesters are activists from Azerbaijan
they say their demonstrations aren't
political but Armenia is accusing them
of blocking the lasheen corridor the
only land link with a disputed enclave
and armenia's Parliament accused
Azerbaijan of causing a shortage of food
medicine and fuel for its 120 000 people
in nagorno-karabakh but the
demonstrators deny their blocking the
road they say they want a ban on what
they call illegal mining in the
mountainous region we are here
conducting this civil form of protests
in order to demand the right of
Azerbaijan to prevent the illegal
exploitation and the stealing of these
resources and here are Russian troops
tasked with a peacekeeping role Armenia
accuses them of failing to stop what it
calls an organized blockade
Armenia and Azerbaijan have been at War
twice over nagorno-karabakh most
recently in 2020 when Russia brokered a
peace deal an estimated 6500 people were
killed in that conflict on the sidelines
of a summit in Saint Petersburg earlier
this week armenia's prime minister made
a complaint to the Russian president
the most urgent issue is the crisis that
we have in the lachin corridor you know
for almost 20 days the corridor has been
closed off and this is a Zone under the
responsibility of the Russian
peacekeepers
the main question is the settlement in
the south caucases in general the
relations between Armenia and Azerbaijan
on the ground the situation appears the
same an independent news agency says it
saw a roadblock near a Russian
checkpoint it's understood that
civilians are being stopped from
returning to the enclave and one Aid
agency says it's been allowed through
with supplies Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera